thank you for bringing us collectively
to this moment it is a moment but so
many have dreamed of claiming history
starts today
[Music]
the guy you were for is an evil person I
don't work for him my firm works for
Emily are you gonna behave yourself
tomorrow I told you more than my job I'm
a reporter I follow people that do not
want to be followed
what about the allegations that you
recruit the most vulnerable for tests
that end up killing people you tell me
so you finish mr. Ross is that a threat
we had to learn how to hide in plain
sight
I'm pretty good at it for you you son
whoever you are if I get a life
foundation and it needs your help we
found something we call them symbiosis
Carleton Drake believes that the union
between human and symbiote is the key to
our evolution
I'm really sick
I'm here boys
you're not real you were just in my head
I'm gonna need mr. Drake's property back
if you're gonna stay you will only hurt
bad people really see it do whatever we
want do we have a deal
you really do sacrifice
the one thing you haul most dear
you should be extremely afraid
what the hell are you we
our feet
[Music]